Good evening.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodasa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
So this evening we'll come to the end of these wonderful expressions of aspiration.
The next one is, so I'm going to do the same so that we overcome our biases, just to listen, catch that reaction, let it go, and then open up to the statement.
Luckily, none of these are controversial, which would cause us to shake our fists and other such demonstrations.
So I find it difficult to choose one above others.
So ideally, I would go for one which involves keeping the precepts.
If this is too wide, I will allow myself to be influenced by our post-truth world and identify the value of truth.
Truth in personal relationships and interpersonal transactions, truth in the corporate world,
and the world of work, truth in politics, don't laugh, as written here, I didn't say that, don't laugh, and to the spiritual truths we seek, the truths of the Dharma.
I find it difficult to choose one above the others, so ideally I would go for one which involves keeping the precepts.
If this is too wide, I will allow myself to be influenced by our post-truth world and identify the value of truth in capitals.
Truth is in personal relationships and interpersonal transactions, truth in the corporate worlds and the world of work, truth in politics, don't laugh, and to the spiritual truths we seek, the truths of the Dharma.
yes true uh not to lie it's in the um or not to tell them truth whatever is in right speech of course not to tell truth it also includes things like um uh calumny talking badly about people um it also includes abusive language and of course just talking for talking sake but the the main thing of course is truthfulness
Yes, we live in a post-truth world.
It's been shocking, really, when you think about it, how politicians like Trump and our own blessed Boris get away with the most astounding lies.
Nobody pulls them up.
You can't take them to court.
Politicians seem to be above the law.
You can actually go on a website which is called Boris Johnson Lies.
And the journalist has listed all the lies, and they're all supported by research, et cetera, et cetera.
And it is extraordinary.
It's not that we ever thought politicians told the truth.
Well, we never thought they told the whole truth.
As Winston Churchill said, a lie is to be economical with the truth.
so you only tell half truth but but some of the stuff that uh we hear from from boris and from uh trump and others is just just completely untrue and and nobody pulls them up about it it's just extraordinary extraordinary but uh on a personal level yes being truthful in our relationships and interpersonal reactions
You could say, couldn't you, that our relationships are based on that honesty, on being honest, open, not hiding things from each other, not exaggerating things.
That's another way you can be dishonest, by exaggerating, exaggeration.
Corporate worlds, of course, but we know we have astounding examples of the cigarette companies, the tobacco companies,
um and all that false research and the same with these oil companies and the research on uh climate change and all that it's awful really absolutely awful and uh we talk about transparency you know and um the government is anything governments are anything but transparent uh so that's just the way it is um
And somehow, you know, we have to keep working, you know, to ask for the truth.
And we're very fortunate in this country that we have a free press.
As you know, what happened in China when somebody was being truthful about coronavirus, you know, they were, I think they were definitely pulled up by the police for being subversive.
So it's an awful state we're in.
lying lying in the monastic rule is a very serious offense and if it's like about your attainments if you if you say that you know you you're an Arahant or something or you've been through all the genres and it's a lie and you know it's a lie and perhaps you've done it in order to get supporters and
um that's a paradjika paradjika means end of life that's how a defeat is often termed as a defeat by which you have to leave the order uh interestingly enough um much in the same way as our politicians um
You can't make a monk leave the order.
I mean, if you're in certain organizations in certain countries, of course, the force of the country, of the order can make you leave, but they can't disrobe you.
All they can do is not accept you in their monastery.
So if somebody declares themselves to be an Arahant, for instance, and has enough lay people who believes them, then he can continue.
There's not much can be done about it.
It's an interesting little point about the order.
I mean, there were people who made that mistake in the Buddha's time.
There's one occasion where there's a monk,
and i'm not actually absolutely clear whether it was a parajika in other words one of these defeats but the buddha wouldn't start the recycle of the of the patimokkha the rule and um moggallana asks him you have to forgive me these little myths i've got the main story i've got the main story right and uh
finally, and they sit all night and finally the Buddha's asked, you know, why aren't you starting?
He said, there's somebody impure, you see.
And Moggallana, that's right, Moggallana with his special abilities could see who it was and actually got hold of him and threw him out of the meeting.
It's about the only bit of violence that seems to occur in the scriptures.
So truth is a
is of course uh absolute an absolute necessity absolute necessity yes i've got here that wonderful moment when uh trump's people came out with this wonderful phrase alternative facts i thought that was absolutely brilliant alternative facts uh and of course uh perhaps some of the hardest thing is to be truthful to ourselves
Sometimes we're not truthful to ourselves, not really open to our own defilements.
I always remember being slightly shocked when I realized that I was jealous.
I was jealous of somebody.
And it took me by surprise because I would have gone around saying, well, I'm not jealous of anybody.
But in fact, on this particular occasion, I was.
And that pulled me up, you see.
So I keep a lookout for that sort of, well, unwholesome mental state.
Jealousy is one of those things that we don't obviously like to accept about ourselves because it diminishes us.
I mean, as soon as you're jealous of somebody, you're saying that they're better than you.
So yes, that truth is something that we could all ponder more on and demand it, demand it of our politicians, especially of our politicians.
Very good.
So the next one is, my thoughts on society is that we need a greater awareness of our interdependence with all human beings, but also all organisms, animals, birds, insects, etc.
Then it wouldn't occur to us that to cause any harm to anything would be peaceful and considerate.
My thoughts on society is that we need a greater awareness of our interdependence with all human beings, but also with organisms such as other organisms, such as animals, birds, insects.
And it wouldn't occur to us to cause any harm to anything.
It would be peaceful and considerate.
and considerate.
So we've had similar expressions of that, of course, interdependence.
Thich Nhat Hanh's poem about I am this, I am that, some of you might know it, I am the flower on the something, you know, it's a bit romantic, but really it's trying to, a poetic way of saying that I am my relationships, I am
That's what I am phenomenally.
I'm my relationship.
I'm a relationship to me.
And as soon as I meet somebody, I become somebody else.
As soon as I'm in nature, I become somebody else.
We're always recreating ourselves within a given situation, within a given environment.
If there's no environment there, then it becomes a real unpleasant place.
I remember in the earlier discourses that I was in the...
In the earlier talks that I was giving, we talked about this confinement, solitary confinement of prisoners and how it can really mess them up psychologically because you need that feed.
You need the feed from other people or else your mind just goes a bit bonkers.
That is, unless you've not got so many defilements.
In the...
In the monk's life, you're not supposed to go out on your own until you've reached the first path and fruit.
Meaning, you know, going into the jungles and all that and the forest and those days because of the danger of losing your mind.
And of course, I'm especially aware of the lack of insects.
I remember just driving from London to Manchester, my home, home of the brave, in the 60s and 70s, and your windscreen, you'd have to get out and wash your windscreen.
The insects would be splattered all over it.
These days you drive anywhere and there's hardly anything that hits the windscreen.
I must say that this year I've noticed more bees and stuff.
But last year I hardly saw any.
So what to do?
And of course it is that interdependence where we begin to realize that when we hurt
When we harm anything out there, we're actually harming ourselves.
That's the thing, isn't it?
That's the interconnectedness, the interdependency.
And it's really beginning to understand that and getting to a position where you try and do as little harm as possible.
Definitely as little harm intentionally as possible.
Next one is my value statement would be, we need to recognise the real relationship of fundamental interdependence that exists between us individuals and social groups, between us as species and the planet, and to start behave accordingly.
So my value statement would be, we need to recognise the real relationship of fundamental interdependence.
that exists between us as individuals and social groups and between us as species and the planet and to start to behave accordingly.
So as I said, I just laid them out as they came in rather than put them in sections, but these two came one after the other.
So obviously, much the same sentiment here.
again this accent that i think we've become more aware of these days of our dependence upon species upon other other beings um especially as i say these insects upon which we so we depend for our food let me say
The next one is regarding regards your request for our thoughts.
What I found most rewarding and liberating is rejoicing in other people's happiness and success.
I find it trickier than feeling compassion for those struggling.
It is somehow much easier to be a bigger person, to find love for someone in need, but the joy that comes from truly feeling happy for someone that is already in a good place and finding generosity to wish them even more happiness.
This has been a lovely, uplifting revelation for me from our evening sittings.
Not an easy one, though.
Regards your request for our thoughts, what I found most rewarding and liberating is rejoicing in other people's happiness and success.
I find it trickier than feeling compassion for those struggling.
It's so much easier to be a bigger person, to find love for someone in need.
For the joy that comes from truly feeling happy for someone that is already in a good place and finding the generosity to wish them even more happiness, this has been a lovely, uplifting revelation for me from our evening sittings.
Not an easy one, though.
I can only guess why.
It's not an easy one, though.
It's something that we don't particularly practice, do we?
Rejoicing in other people's success.
I mean, we do it on birthdays, of course, and special days like marriages and births and all that.
But we don't go around rejoicing in people so much.
And
It's a sort of, it's another level of connection, isn't it?
So you have love and care, you have compassion when people are not in a good place.
And then this sense of rejoicing in people's success, in people's abilities.
recognizing people's abilities and rejoicing in it and of course that that lifts the heart tremendously and you have to do it to yourself too you have to rejoice in your in in our own qualities in our own success and this this lifts us if we don't do that um the tendency is always to think negatively
It's to think how I could have been.
The glass is always half empty.
It's not half full.
And that's what joy does.
It sort of balances out the more negative feelings we have towards us because most of us never feel good enough.
We're always lacking something.
It could have been better.
It's to do with comparison, and comparison is a form of conceit.
So there are three conceits, you know, I'm better than you, so that makes me feel much, that makes me feel good.
I'm worse than you, that doesn't make me feel very good, but it's somehow, there's a sort of an inverted pride and I can take comfort in it, you know, I can excuse my failures because I'm not as good as you.
And then there's a more subtle one of we are equal.
Now, at first you might think, oh, well, that's egalitarian.
That's perfectly all right.
But of course, when you look into it, when you say that we're equal, what we're saying is that you and me are part of this group who are equal, but actually we're superior or inferior to others.
So it's a sort of communal conceit.
So rejoicing, and of course, it undermines that near enemy of envy and jealousy.
So yes, it's a lovely thing to practice.
And we also had, I think we had somewhere, if I remember rightly, we had generosity and a sense of, I mean, what actually goes to support that is gratitude.
thankfulness.
When we develop a certain level of gratitude, then we're much more open to the qualities that people have and to the things they've achieved.
So, yes.
Sympathetic joy.
It is one of the four Brahma Viharas.
It's one of the four dwelling places of Brahma.
So what the Buddha is saying there is that this is one of the greatest mental states we can develop.
And I have to say, it's not often taught.
I don't remember doing any in all my training.
I mean, it was there, of course.
One is happy.
But there's no specific training.
Any time.
in any of my um spiritual practice you know in buddhism uh to do with joy uh i have put you on to that book by the way i mentioned it before awakening joy by james barras very good so now uh today um i had an email which um
which nicely sums up everything for me.
So I've not had to think about how to draw these questions to a conclusion.
I've been enjoying the exploration of values over the last few days.
It is fascinating to see how the different perfections all link up so that each one of them can become an entry point to developing all of them.
That works nicely with the diversity of humanity.
My initial response to your question, which value would be most fundamental, was humility.
It's not one of the power of me, that's one of the ten affections.
On reflection, I see it as related to generosity.
Both imply that my own needs and opinions are not of more value than those of others around me or far away, and allow for the possibility that my own views may be limited, that another person may be as blind
and that their view is as limited as mine, holding a different part of the same elephant and describing the whole beast from their own perspective.
If enough of us could come together to share our limited perspectives openly and without clinging, then between us a fuller picture of reality might emerge and hopefully lead to a better collective and individual actions in the world.
I can now see that it also all links up with renunciation, in particular of ego-driven views.
The paramis are an area that I have so far not greatly looked at, partly believing that it was necessary to get rid of the taints before they can develop.
If I understood you rightly last night, both processes can actually happen in parallel.
That's great and encouraging to hear.
Of course, thinking about it, the two are like positive and negative images.
By developing the perfections, I can start reducing the taints and vice versa.
So these are lovely ending paragraphs for us.
And as I say, I've relieved me of any duty of drawing things up.
So I shall read it again.
I've been enjoying the exploration of values over the last few days and it's fascinating to see how the different perfections all link up so that each one of them can become an entry point to developing all of them.
That works nicely with the diversity of humanity.
My initial response to your question, which value would be most fundamental, was humility.
It's not one of the parami, the perfections,
On reflection, I see it as related to generosity.
Both imply my own needs and opinions are not of more value than those of others around me or far away, and allow for the possibility that my own views may be limited, that another person may be as blind and their view as limited as mine, holding a different part of the same elephant and describing the whole beast from their own perspective.
If enough of us can come together to share our limited perspectives openly and without clinging, then between us a fuller picture of reality will emerge and hopefully lead to a better collective and individual actions in the world.
I can see now that it all links up with renunciation, in particular the ego-driven views.
The param is an area I've
so far not greatly looked at, partly believing that it's necessary to get rid of the taints before they can develop.
I understood you right last night.
Both processes can actually happen in parallel.
That's great and encouraging to hear.
Of course, thinking about it, the two are like positive and negative images.
By developing the perfections, I can start reducing the taints and vice versa.
Yeah, that's a lovely conclusion for us.
I think that's a really good point that, you know, it manifests our diversity, all these different views, but also our fundamental unity, which he later points out.
This image of the elephant, that's an old Indian image about, an old Indian simile about blind men feeling an elephant and then saying, well, saying that it's a brush, the tail, or it's a stump of a tree, the leg, completely misunderstanding the elephant as a total.
And that's what happens when we cling to a view or an opinion and we think that we've got it all.
It's a case of seeing our views and opinions, as he said, as a perspective.
This business of working with the taints when they come up, but also developing the power of me.
Yes, indeed, that's what we're instructed to do.
And remember that the energy or the malevolent energy or the turbulences that come with the defilements, that energy is not lost.
It is transformed.
In fact, the word I prefer is sublimate.
It moves directly from the...
the unwholesome state directly into the wholesome and sometimes you might actually experience that I remember I was having a hard time with my teacher once and I was on doing a personal retreat and I was working with this real deep disappointment I had in him and it came up with a lot of aversion
And being a very good meditator at that time, I just stayed with the feeling, stayed with the feeling.
And to my real honest surprise, it just turned in front of me into this really warm, compassionate feeling for him.
And that manifested for me that these energies, they just turn.
they evaporate and become something else.
So you can work on both.
Yes, on that last line, the bit about...
hopefully lead to a better collective and individual actions of the world.
I was told a story by Nori, she was in Bulgaria, and somebody told her that he was in Sofia, the capital, and just noticed that lots of people were walking towards the center.
And so he joined in.
And a whole crowd began to develop in the central square.
And then one man got up and began to talk about all the people, all his relatives or friends who'd gone missing in the communist era and stuff like that.
And more and more people got up to talk about their grievances.
And the building, the government building behind them was full of lights, it seems.
And eventually, when everything had been spoken, seemingly everybody turned
and looked into the building and all the lights started to go out.
And there's a presumption that they were all escaping.
And from that moment onwards, it seems the communist government began to give in.
And of course, that was all around 89 when the wall collapsed.
And looking back at that time, generally speaking, what a peaceful revolution that was, you know.
you know, comparing to the earlier times when there were uprisings in Hungary, 56, I think, which were brutally suppressed, you know.
So the whole purpose of us really, you know, considering these different
qualities is to really begin to see how they can manifest through our economics and our social life even personally individually it might
make us much more aware of what we're buying, what we're eating, etc., etc., and how we talk to others, how we actually begin to persuade others, especially those whom we meet who have opposite views and opinions, perhaps to get them to open up to our views and for us to understand theirs.
I mean, we've been through this whole Brexit thing where it was very difficult for some people who were for staying to understand that anybody could want to leave, you know.
And there's all this thing about them being a bit thick.
They didn't understand.
And, of course, it was one of the fundamental reasons that people wanted to leave was that they just weren't benefiting.
They saw nothing but...
their own poverty and the immigration had made them feel a loss of, this is the white, the English people and the Welsh had made them, their sense of community was being undermined.
Anyway, that's what we have to do.
We have to keep these values, these virtues in our minds and
whenever the opportunity comes to say what's necessary, to be open about it, not to be afraid.
And hopefully we shall move towards a very wonderful and enlightened society in no length of time.
We can hope.
So with those wonderful words, let us now begin our practice.